[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend in allen heute ist der 500 Tag
seit Beginn des russischen Krieges gegen
die Ukraine jeder einzelne davon ist
einer zu viel nach Angaben der
UNO-Mission zur Überwachung der
Menschenrechte in der Ukraine sind seit
Anfang der Invasion mehr als 9000
Zivilisten getötet worden darunter 500
Kinder der Präsident der Ukraine wurde
mir selenski veröffentlicht heute ein
Video das Ihnen zeigt auf der
Schlangeninsel im Schwarzen Meer die auf
Briefmarken Aufklebern und T-Shirts in
der Ukraine als Symbol des Widerstands
und durchhalte willenskillt
wie sehr dieser Widerstand allerdings
und der Erfolg der ukrainischen gegen
Offensive am Nachschub hängt zeigt unser
Reporter daran
Blumen bete als Symbol der Hoffnung Ruin
als Resultat von 500 Tagen Krieg
und doch haben sich viele Ukraine ihre
Widerstandskraft bewahrt wie Vladimir
dieses Militärfahrzeug hat er Mechaniker
für die Armee gebaut es ist eine
Testfahrt der Ukraine fehlen ausreichend
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge um ihre Truppen
geschützt an der Front zu bewegen sein
Buggy ist das Gegenteil offen und leicht
nur die Geschwindigkeit schützt vor
Treffern immer wieder in diesem Krieg
muss die ukrainische Armee improvisieren
man erreicht schnell seine Position
feuert seine Salben oder evakuiert
Soldaten und fliegt davon für den Feind
ist der Wagen schwer zu entdecken und zu
treffen
die Idee zu diesem fahrzeugkampf
Wladimir als er hörte das Soldaten ihre
verletzten teils zu Fuß von der Front
wegtragen mussten Monate lang tüftel der
er am ersten Prototyp jetzt stellt seine
Manufaktur in fünf Tagen ein Buggy her
es könnten mehr sein man findet im
Moment nur sehr schwer gute schweißer
und Mechaniker und die wenigen verlangen
ein für uns kaum bezahlbares Gehalt über
1000 € im Monat gerade Mechaniker werden
bevorzugt von der Armee eingezogen an
altem Stall und Motoren zum
Ausschlachten mangelt es hingegen nicht
unsere Fahrzeuge sind robuster aber wie
lange sie im Einsatz sind hängt vom
Glück des Fahrers ab
und von seinem Geschick sich zu tarnen
und Minen zu umfahren
manches seiner Fahrzeuge übersteht nur
wenige Tage an der Front doch sollte nur
ein Soldaten Leben gerettet worden sein
dann habe sich der Aufwand gelohnt
zervladimir zurück im leeren die
ukrainische Armee konnte die Stadt im
letzten Jahr zurückerobern auf solche
Erfolge hoffen Sie in der Ukraine weiter
die politische Lage in Eritrea in
Ostafrika hatte heute folgen bis nach
Mittelhessen die Polizei in Gießen rief
zwischenzeitlich das sie Ried
zwischenzeitlich das Stadtgebiet zum
meiden weil es massive Ausschreitungen
gab tumultartiges Szenen mit Verletzten
und Festgenommenen anlass war ein
Festival dass die Veranstalter als
Familienfest angemeldet haben das aber
wohl mehr ist ein Brennpunkt weil die
Gegner das Regimes in Eritrea dahinter
den langen Arm der Diktatur sehen
Eritrea ist international weitgehend
abgeschottet wird seit 30 Jahren von
einem ehemaligen Unabhängigkeitskämpfer
mit harter Hand regiert und verlangt
Zwangssteuer an von seinen Bürgern im
Ausland Susanna
noch bevor das Eritrea Festival heute
begann nahm die Polizei am frühen Morgen
rund 60 Personen Gewahrsam über ein
Social media-video hatte man Hinweise
bekommen dass Angriffe auf die
Veranstaltung in den Hessenhallen in
Gießen geplant waren die gewalttätigen
Auseinandersetzungen später konnten
dadurch nicht verhindert werden
Polizisten wurden mit Flaschen und
Steinen beworfen 22 Beamte wurden
verletzt die Demonstranten sollen
versucht haben Absperrungen zu
durchbrechen die Polizei reagierte mit
Wasserwerfern und Schlagstöcken
die Veranstaltungen die in den
Messehallen stattfindet zu stören es ist
zu verschiedenen Straftaten gekommen
Sachbeschädigung Widerstand gegen
Vollstreckungsbeamte
Körperverletzungsdelikte und wir
ermitteln auch wegen des Verdachts des
schweren Landfriedensbruchs mit mehr als
1.000 Einsatzkräften ist die Polizei in
Gießen im Einsatz beim Eritrea Festival
kommt es in den letzten Jahren immer
wieder zu gewalttätigen
Auseinandersetzungen die Demonstranten
werfen den Veranstaltern vor
Regierungspropaganda zu verbreiten viele
von ihnen sind vor der Militärdiktatur
in Eritrea nach Deutschland geflohen und
können nicht verstehen dass eine solche
Veranstaltung hier erlaubt wird
der Veranstalter der Zentralrat der
Eritrea in Deutschland weiß den Vorwurf
zurück mit dem Festival Propaganda für
die Militärregierung zu machen diese
Vorwurf besteht seit vielen Jahren aber
das ist haltlos so wie man es hier sieht
das sind hier werden kulturelle
Veranstaltungen gemacht und literarische
Wettbewerb musikalische Darbietung also
das ist gar nicht so Propaganda hessens
Innenminister Peter Beuth verurteilte
heute die so wörtlich Gewalt Eskalation
mit gezielten Angriffen gegen
Einsatzkräfte er forderte die
Bundesregierung auf den eritreischen
Botschafterin zu bestellen
und die Nachrichtenübersicht beginnt
jetzt mit der politischen Lage bei
unseren Nachbarn in den Niederlanden ja
die nach dem Auseinanderbrechen der
niederländischen
Ministerpräsident rütte König Wilhelm
Alexander den Rücktritt des Kabinetts
angeboten und Ihnen heute zu einem
persönlichen Gespräch getroffen die
vierer-koalition war gestern Abend an
einem Streit um die Migrationspolitik
zerbrochen ist voraussichtlich im Herbst
zu rechnen
der türkische Präsident Erdogan hat
überraschend seine Unterstützung für
eine Aufnahme der Ukraine in die NATO
erklärt nach einem Treffen mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten silensky sagte
Erdogan das Land habe eine
NATO-Mitgliedschaft zweifellos verdient
zudem versprach Erdogan sich für eine
Verlängerung des baldauslaufenden
getreideabkommens zwischen Moskau und
Kiew einzusetzen
die USA haben laut US-Präsident beiden
ihre letzten chemiewaffenbestände
vernichtet das sei ein wichtiger
Meilenstein erklärte die Kontrollbehörde
zum Verbot von Chemiewaffen durch den
Schritt seien nun alle weltweit
offiziell gemeldeten chemischen Waffen
zerstört worden dennoch stehen einige
Staaten im Verdacht weiterhin nicht
deklarierte Chemiewaffen zu besitzen
darunter Syrien und Russland
in Israel haben die Proteste gegen die
umstrittene Justizreform der
rechtsreligiösen Regierung wieder an
Fahrt aufgenommen kurz bevor am Montag
eine Abstimmung im Parlament dazu
ansteht allein in Tel Aviv gingen laut
Medienberichten mehr als 140.000
Menschen auf die Straße in den
vergangenen Wochen waren die Proteste
zurückgegangen israels Ministerpräsident
Netanjahu hatte die Reform im März
vorübergehend gestoppt und kürzlich dann
in abgeschwächter Form wieder auf die
Agenda gesetzt
über Montevideo die Hauptstadt von
Uruguay berichten wir vergleichsweise
selten was schade ist denn wer mal dort
war kann eigentlich gar nicht anders als
dieser Stadt zu verfallen ihrer Lage
ihrer Architektur ihren Menschen wenn
Sie mich fragen Montevideo ist mit
Sicherheit einer der schönsten Orte auf
dieser Welt und einer der jetzt mit
massiven Problemen kämpft Montevideo
geht das Trinkwasser aus ein Albtraum
mit Ansage wie christopherath berichtet
einer auch mit leeren für uns
ein Schluck Wasser für Julio Gabriela
den Parkplatz Wächter im Stadtpark von
Montevideo er hat gehört dass die
Stadtverwaltung gerade mitten in seinem
Park einen Brunnen geboren hat und er
hat Durst
es ist besser als das Leitungswasser das
ist salzig das hier ist süßes Wasser
lecker
der Brunnen ist der ganze Stolz von
Lazaro tassesia und seinen Kollegen seit
es kein sauberes Leitungswasser mehr
gibt müssen sie improvisieren seit dem
Morgen fließt hier frisches Grundwasser
aus dem Boden in Tanklaster geht ja
nicht diese Bohrungen versorgen direkt
die Krankenhäuser und das werden wir
beibehalten damit uns so eine Not nie
wieder passiert
die Region um Montevideo der Hauptstadt
Uruguays mit fast 2 Millionen Bewohnern
leidet unter der schlimmsten Dürre seit
Jahrzehnten die zwei Stauseen die die
Stadt versorgen sind so gut wie
ausgetrocknet obwohl die Region
normalerweise sehr wasserreich ist neben
klimatischen Faktoren machen
Wissenschaftler die Agrarpolitik der
letzten Jahrzehnte verantwortlich
diese Krise hat ihren Anfang schon vor
vielen Jahrzehnten genommen als im
Einzugsgebiet der Flüsse die
Landwirtschaft intensiviert wurde das
hat zu Boden der Generation zu Boden
Erosion und dem Verlust der
Wasseraufnahmefähigkeit der Böden
geführt
seit kaum noch Frischwasser Montevideo
erreicht pumpen Sie salziges Wasser aus
der meeresmündung des Rio de la Plata
ins Netz das Leitungswasser wird
ungenießbar aber ohne würde das Netz
zusammenbrechen
im schlimmsten Fall hätten wir gar kein
Leitungswasser mehr also auch kein
funktionierendes Abwassersystem so
können wir zwar kein Trinkwasser
bereitstellen aber immerhin das
Abwassersystem aufrecht erhalten was
essentiell ist für das Funktionieren der
Stadt
Trinkwasser gibt es nur noch aus
Flaschen trotz Subventionen viel zu
teuer für die Ärmsten Lourdes mouninho
bekocht jeden Tag die Kinder aus ihrem
Viertel jetzt mehr denn je darauf
angewiesen sind
wenn die Kinder das Wasser aus dem Hahn
trinken bekommen sie Bauchschmerzen sie
Erbrechen das sind die Folgen des
Salzwassers
gerade unter den armsten geht die Angst
vor
es gibt keine Antwort darauf wie diese
Situation gelöst werden soll sie sagen
das Wasser könnte noch salziger werden
es könnte also noch schlimmer kommen
wissenschaftler vermuten dass sich die
Situation erst in Monaten verbessern
durfte
es ist eine Warnung an die uruguayische
Gesellschaft aber auch an den Rest der
Welt
denn das Beispiel Montevideo zeigt wenn
man auf die Warnzeichen der Natur nicht
rechtzeitig reagiert gibt es irgendwann
keinen schnellen Ausweg mehr
wer maximale Kontrolle will auch über
das Internet für den muss künstliche
Intelligenz wie etwa das intelligente
Chatprogramm Chat GPT schon mal generell
wie eine Bedrohung erscheinen alle mit
künstlicher Intelligenz erzeugten
Inhalte müssen sozialistische Grundwerte
verkörpern so steht das in neuen Regeln
die demnächst in China gelten sollen das
ist wohl mit ein Grund warum China bei
Chatbots und computergenerierten
Sprachsystemen erstaunlich weit
zurückliegt
andererseits läuft in Shanghai aktuell
die Weltkonferenz für künstliche
Intelligenz mit einem neuen
Ausstellerrekord Elisabeth Schmidt ist
dort
wie sieht die Kreuzung zwischen einer
Katze und einem Seehund aus wie das
Pop-Up Portrait eines messebesuches ein
paar Stichworte genügen einen
Wimpernschlag später spuckt die
künstliche Intelligenz 4 Vorschläge aus
earlybot heißt der chinesische
Konkurrent zum amerikanischen Chat er
ist der Star auf der ki-messe in
Shanghai
der Chatbot kann vieles Texte erstellen
reden schreiben oder unseren Urlaub
planen
Spielerei aber auch digitales Wettrüsten
mit den USA ganze 79 sprachmodelle sind
in China bereits entwickelt worden die
Chat GPT Konkurrenz machen sollen
geschafft hat es bislang keine Ernie bot
spricht nur chinesisch er ist noch nicht
frei verfügbar und darf auch nicht alle
Fragen beantworten meine zum Beispiel
was der Bot über den chinesischen
Präsidenten weiß
es ist verboten nach dem Präsidenten zu
fragen sie können ihn etwas anderes
fragen
nicht über Politik
man ist nicht in der Lage alle möglichen
Wege wie Menschen vielleicht fragen zu
fragen werden kontrolliert zu
kontrollieren und hat deswegen eben die
Angst dass es irgendwie einen Weg geben
könnte mit denen dann rauskommt schien
den pingen hat in shinjang
Menschenrechtsverletzungen begangen die
Staatsführung bremst selbstlernende
Systeme bei sensiblen Themen
sicherheitshalber von vornherein aus ein
Nachteil für die Entwicklung von KI in
China woran es außerdem mangelt hoch
entwickelte Chips und Halbleiter die USA
haben Exporte nach China beschränkt die
Entwicklung im eigenen Land hängt
hinterher doch die Schere Masse an
ki-anwendungen ist beachtlich viele sind
bereits im Alltag im Einsatz
dieser operationsroboter hat schon mehr
als 1000 OP ist in gut 40 Kliniken in
über 20 chinesischen Provinzen
durchgeführt
menschenähnliche Roboter laufen dagegen
noch recht wackelig übers Parkett doch
die Staatsführung hat bereits Milliarden
Summen an Fördermitteln angekündigt für
Beobachter ein Grund zur Sorge er geht
es um Überwachung von Uiguren und
anderen chinesischen
Staatsbürgern da geht es aber auch um
die Anwendung im Militär wo eben die
chinesische Regierung auch wirklich sehr
viel Ressourcen investiert künstliche
Intelligenz soll das Leben der Menschen
leichter machen in China soll die KI in
erster Linie einer dienen der
Kommunistischen Partei
und jetzt der Blick auf die Lottozahlen
an diesem Samstag die lauten drei 14 25
29 37 44 Superzahl 0 alle Angaben wie
immer ohne Gewähr
auch morgen wird es wieder heiß der
Deutsche Wetterdienst hat eine
Hitzewarnung herausgegeben die
Aussichten morgen drohen im Westen und
Nordwesten heftige Gewitter sonst ist es
meist sonnig die Wärmebelastung ist
stark bis extrem bei schwül heißen 27
bis 38 Grad die neue Woche bringt
weitere Schauer und Gewitter im
Nordwesten wird es weniger warm im Osten
und Süden bleibt es aber heiß bei 20 bis
35 Grad damit schicken wir sie in diese
sommer-nacht ja und die nächste heute
Express gibt es hier gegen 0 Uhr bis
morgen hier aus dem klimatisierten
Studio wenn Sie mögen angenehmer
[Musik]